[Music]
on this saturday night
the votes are in a record number
cast ballots for the next conservative
party leader a look at the lineup and
what a new poll reveals about their
chances of defeating justin trudeau
the golden state calls for backup i
could have
20 000 firefighters that love to have
them
hundreds of wildfires consume california
as residents near penticton bc
keep a nervous eye on the sky
and the nba's coach of the year award
goes
to the north it's a humbling award it
really is
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple good evening and thank you
for joining us
the race to replace andrew scheer as
conservative party leader has now
reached the finish line
all of the ballots are in and the victor
will be announced tomorrow
four candidates are vying for that top
job derek sloane aaron o'toole peter
mckay and leslie lewis but we won't know
the winner until all the votes are
counted
and here's a look at the vault where
those ballots are being stored
more than 174 000 votes were cast that
is a new canadian record
for the election of any federal party
leader all votes were mailed in because
of covid 19.
and as the liberal government grapples
with the fallout from the we charity
controversy and with parliament probed
until september
a new poll reveals that canadians could
be swayed by a new conservative leader
ipsa's polling done exclusively for
global news found 49 percent of
canadians
say they may consider voting for the
conservative party with a new leader
of the candidates peter mckay was the
most popular with 39
support followed closely by aaron
o'toole at 35 percent
with derrick sloane and leslie lewis at
31 and 30
respectively abigail beeman takes a
closer look at the four candidates for
the conservatives top job
and their chances of becoming the next
prime minister
no hyphenated conservatives let's all
get behind a conservative plan and a
leader who can win
the perceived front runner in the race
to replace andrew scheer is a
conservative with roots
so deep in the party peter mckay
co-founded its current incarnation
in the 2003 merger between his pc party
and stephen harper's canadian alliance
mckay held high-profile cabinet
positions including foreign affairs and
justice
the nova scotian left politics in 2015
and went back to practicing law
the canadian public is prepared to look
at him as a potential prime minister
but the interesting thing to me is that
he doesn't have a really big lead over
his biggest alternatives
so all of the candidates all four of
them do 30
or better with the canadian population
in terms of of approvals
erin o'toole was also a harper cabinet
minister of veterans affairs
the greater toronto area mp spent 12
years in the royal canadian air force
and worked as a lawyer
canadians know we need a serious prime
minister again i'm going to offer that
from my business experience cabinet
experience military experience
i'm in it for canadians and while
o'toole and mckay are in the lead in
both polling and fundraising
toronto lawyer leslie lewis has
impressed men i think
the greatest thing that could have
happened to the conservative party
what's been a boring
slow uneventful and exciting race is a
a new conservative new potential
conservative star in leslie lewis
she's the first black woman to seek the
conservative leadership
lewis is also open about her social
conservative views
i don't think that marching in a parade
um is
is indicative of how well you'll treat
canadians
you know i see it as something that will
advance my political career
and i don't feel it's necessary to use a
group to do that
mr speaker rounding out the race another
social conservative rookie mp derek
sloane
perhaps best known for his attack on
canada's chief public health officer dr
teresa tam
does she work for canada or for china
and the backdrop of the global pandemic
made for an unusual race
with campaigning constraints and the
final results to be announced
virtually obviously the covid lockdown
made it a very complicated undertaking
to be a good
candidate in a general election and a
good prime minister thereafter you have
to be able
to adapt also likely due to the pandemic
ipsos polling shows there isn't a lot of
interest
generally among canadians for this race
but within the conservative movement
there has been
record-breaking turnout with close to
175
thousand ballots cast by friday's
deadline official counting
begins sunday at 4am with results
announced
sunday night abigail beeman global news
ottawa
and global news will have live
continuous coverage of the conservative
leadership vote as it unfolds on sunday
starting at 6
pm eastern time that's 3 pacific you can
watch it live on our website
globalnews.ca
the global news youtube channel or on
the global tv app
and of course we'll also have the
results and analysis right here
on global national the tories have been
hammering the liberals hard over the we
charity controversy and this past week
saw more revelations from thousands of
internal government documents
not to mention the resignation of the
federal finance minister
and the prorogation of parliament lots
to unpack there and mercedes stevenson
joins me now with a look ahead to the
west block
mercedes
canadians can be forgiven if they're
having trouble keeping up with the
latest developments here in ottawa
it has been a staggering week first came
finance minister bill morneau's
resignation on monday
that led to a cabinet shuffle on tuesday
with deputy prime minister
christia freeland taking the reins as
canada's first female finance minister
but then came the moment that political
watchers had been eagerly anticipating
for weeks
a massive drop of documents tied to the
wii controversy
thousands of pages of briefing notes and
emails
many of them redacted raising even more
questions about the government's
decision
to award a sole source deal to we to
manage a student grant program
in light of what those documents
revealed i asked employment minister
carla qualtro
if she was worried that canadians might
hear echoes of the old liberal party
bogged down by allegations of cronyism
here's how she responded
you know i think canadians see the big
picture i think canadians will
look back at how we've managed this
crisis over the past months and see that
we we dug in we did our very best for
them we weren't perfect we
we knew we would have to course correct
we you know we knew
things wouldn't be we we had ideas we
tried them some didn't work some did
maybe we didn't pay attention on on
particular
files as much as we could have but i
think canadians will understand the
context of what
was going on when all of this was going
on down and the things that were being
thrown at us
every day as a government were really
big and we did our very best and i think
they'll see that
also on the show i spoke with
conservative finance critic
pierre pauliev and the ndp's deputy
ethics critic
matthew green as you might expect they
say the prime minister
shouldn't expect the wii scandal to go
away just because
he decided to prorogue parliament and
with the conservatives set to pick their
new leader tomorrow
i'll check in with pollster darrell
bricker on what we should expect
all that and more ahead on the west
block well it's an
anxious game of wait and see in british
columbia this weekend as thousands of
people living in the province's okanagan
valley remain on a wildfire evacuation
alert
the hot spot is near penticton bc and
what's known as the christie mountain
wildfire it covers approximately two
thousand hectares
global's aaron macarthur is watching the
situation on the ground for us in
penticton
erin jeff the fire is
still burning smoke is clearly still
visible
above the city of penticton but the
collective feeling here in the okanagan
is one of relief
helicopters are focusing their attention
on the canyons
east of the city the fire still burning
but according to fire officials the
activity about the same as it was friday
over last night there was maybe around
35 additional hectares in growth just
with some of the wind from yesterday
but the fire activity has been fairly
minimal
the concern on friday was the wind 60
kilometer an hour gusts creating ideal
conditions for the fire to move quickly
closer to homes crews spent much of the
day preparing to fight
an interface fire protecting homes with
wet lines and sprinklers
saturday penticton's fire chief now
believes the danger
has passed firefighters from communities
across bc
have been sent home we feel very
confident that the fire is no longer
threatening structures
adjacent to the fire in the in the city
of penticton however we are still
working
on behalf of the regional district for
structure protection and we'll continue
to do that until there's no longer a
threat to those structures
300 families are still out of their
homes in the fire zone
and the evacuation alert continues for 3
700
more and while the immediate danger may
have passed it will take crews
weeks to get an upper hand on this fire
jeff global's aaron mcarthur in
penticton bc for us tonight thanks aaron
and wildfires raging in california are
only getting worse and now there are
fears that lightning in the forecast
could spark further fires
at least 560 blazes are burning across
the state right now
most in the north fire officials say at
least 400
000 hectares have been scorched so far
tonight 140
000 californians are under evacuation
orders
as more than 12 thousand firefighters
battle the flames
they're running on fumes some of them
working 24-hour shifts
and as jennifer johnson reports the
governor is now calling on canada
to help this driver captured almost
apocalyptic scenes of an out of control
fire
one of hundreds incinerating parts of
central and northern california
relentless heat and repeated lightning
strikes have set the state ablaze
countless homes have been destroyed we
left and this is what we came home to
today
in the state's famous napa and sonoma
wine regions less than 10 percent of the
lnu
lightning complex fire is contained
firefighters have taken to the air to
fight back
on the ground electric power lines are
sparking and gas tanks erupting
you could hear this swirling swishing of
air and just
going crazy and explosions going off
a daring rescue and gusty winds saved
two [ __ ] firefighters friday night
about an hour east of san francisco
the infernos are taking their toll as
state officials put out a call for more
help
crews from 10 other states are on their
way firefighters from canada and
australia
are coming too in regards to the amount
of firefighters ideally
if i could have 20 000 firefighters that
love to have them but that's just not
the reality
some desperate homeowners are taking
matters into their own hands
i want to save the neighborhood just a
little a little path like this can you
know save one one home two homes that's
enough for me the fires have burned
larger areas of california in just two
weeks
then wildfires usually scorch in an
entire year
air quality is so bad in san francisco
and los angeles
residents are being warned to stay
inside we have the kind of
the double hit right when we have smoke
impacts from fires as well as the smog
impacts because
of the weather conditions really you're
breathing in both at the same time
officials say if you're told to evacuate
a region get out
despite concerns about the potential
spread of covet 19 in shelters
if you're in the area and you don't need
to be there please leave let us do our
job
but firefighters are stretched so thin
no one can predict how long it will take
to get
all these fires extinguished jennifer
johnson
global news washington and further south
the u.s gulf coast is on high alert as
two tropical storms are picking up steam
in the caribbean
and packing a double punch laura and
marco
are projected to crash into the coast
next week potentially as hurricanes and
could devastate parts of texas and
louisiana
americans are being advised to plan
ahead already puerto rico and the u.s
virgin islands have been hammered with
heavy rain and high winds
this would be just the second time in
recorded history that two
tropical storms have battered the coast
simultaneously
the first was back in 1959.
and to a political storm now over the
possible poisoning of one of the russian
president's biggest rivals opposition
leader alexi navalny is undergoing
emergency medical treatment in germany
flown there after drinking what his
supporters say was poisoned tea
now they claim the kremlin is trying to
cover it up
the outspoken critic of vladimir putin
was rushed to hospital in berlin today
on a stretcher
and he remains in an induced coma
navalny was seen drinking tea from a cup
while waiting to board a flight from
siberia to moscow on thursday
he was heard screaming before collapsing
on the plane
still ahead canada's race to develop a
covid19 vaccine
hits a mysterious snag
plus a missing star a push to honor a
hollywood trailblazer
welcome back as countries around the
world reimpose measures to slow the
spread of kovid 19
the death toll is climbing fast 800
000 people around the globe have now
died from covid19
more than 9 000 of those in canada
countries are scrambling to produce a
vaccine and it's now been three months
since a vaccine candidate was approved
for canadian trials
it's being produced in china with funds
from canada but it still hasn't arrived
as redmond shannon reports the
unexplained delay
is sparking concerns in may it seemed
like
canada was in a good position for one of
the early front-runners in the covit 19
vaccine race
if these vaccine trials are successful
we can produce
and distribute it here at home that
potential vaccine is being developed by
cancino in china
using cells provided by canada's
national research council
a similar deal resulted in a successful
ebola vaccine in 2017.
but three months on from the covet 19
deal and the potential vaccine is
still not in canadian hands even though
phase 3 cancino trials are due to start
soon
elsewhere a chinese patent has been
granted
and the vaccine is already being used in
the chinese military
of all the vaccine candidates that are
out there which one did canada choose to
partner with
one that is owned by a company closely
allied to china's military at a moment
when canada's relationship with china is
the worst it's ever been
the national research council says the
delay is caused by
chinese customs it's really anyone's
guess as to
what's behind this delay professor
matthew herter says taxpayers should
know all the details of this deal
as well as those of recent partnerships
between ottawa and
vaccine makers pfizer and moderna all of
these deals have a fair bit of risk
involved so what steps are being taken
what protections are built into them to
make sure that
we don't invest a ton of money and
ultimately gain nothing from that
relationship in parliamentary documents
innovation minister navdy baines
said kansano owns all intellectual
property rights for the vaccines it
develops
many of canada's allies including the uk
the us and
australia have ordered hundreds of
millions of doses of an arguably
more promising vaccine developed by
oxford university
and astrazeneca a spokesperson for
procurement minister anita anand said
ottawa is currently
exploring every option we're in an
incredibly vulnerable place
because we've gathered and we've not
been effective this week the pope
and the world health organization
appealed for worldwide cooperation on
vaccines
but it's already a cut throat and canada
needs to keep up redmond shannon global
news london
still ahead the trail blazing star
missing from hollywood's walk of fame
you're watching global national
[Music]
welcome back here's some hollywood
trivia for you what actor
has the most credits to their name the
answer is 91 year old james hung
now if you don't know his name you'll
likely recognize his face
the chinese-american actor has been cast
in more than 600 roles
and after a campaign raised tens of
thousands of dollars
the star could finally make his debut on
the walk
of fame mike drollet explains
dinner tonight very fresh if you've
watched any tv or movies over the past
seven decades there's no doubt you've
seen
this actor his name may elude you
but you know him everything started
since its arrival
this was one of james hong's first tv
appearances all told he has
over 600 credits to his name including a
handful of classics like blade runner
you not come here illegal the roles he
played were often
crude stereotypes but he did it well
he was forced into a box for
chinese-american actors that's just
that's the reality of the 40s 5060s when
he came up as an actor and now
he has weathered it all he has done
enough stuff that has resonated that has
lasted that has endured that people
genuinely love him another actor daniel
day kim loves him so much that he's
launched a campaign to get the 91 year
old a star
on the hollywood walk of fame which
vancouver-based actor
rogie yoo says is long overdue he was
probably one of the first if not the
first
face on a big screen
that looked like mine like hong you
decided to be an actor against the
advice of his parents who didn't see
opportunity like at the very beginning
of my career close to 30 years ago
you know i'd go to my agency and and i'd
say show me the breakdowns
and the descriptions were literally
no asians please singapore colin's
wedding
don't you want to be my family the
recent success of asian-centric movies
in hollywood
have opened a few more doors and
eliminated that no asians role
description from
call sheets now don't get me wrong i'm
not saying it's all great now
no i'm just saying the wording is
different now
and it gets me into the room more often
it's no small thing to say hong help
pave the way for actors
like roguei you hollywood recognition or
not
he's a star don't take the cricket from
my head microlight global news toronto
well there's at least one canadian
hockey team not singing the blues
see what i did there next how the
vancouver canucks scored big
in the nhl's pandemic playoffs
and canada's only nba team the toronto
raptors is also
celebrating tonight the man who led them
to their first championship in 2019 nick
nurse
has now been named the nba coach of the
year
and he learned the news from his own
former coach
congratulations on being the
nba coach of the year for
2019 2020
holy cow
nurse became emotional when his high
school coach wayne chandley delivered
the news
on tnt and true to form nurse was ready
with a joke
research i think nobody really wants to
coach they want to play but but then
when you're playing career ends
you want to stay close to it you start
coaching and um
just love being around the team and
trying to get guys to
dream about success and help lead them
there you know
nurse became the raptors head coach in
2018 after working as the team's
assistant coach for five years he's
helped to shatter
franchise records including toronto's
first championship and regular season
winning streaks
and he's the third coach in raptor's
history to win that award
congrats nick let's go raptors and that
is global national for this saturday i'm
jeff
semple tonight's your canada is horse
thief canyon
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here tomorrow
[Music]
you